all right so
2020 for being honest wasn't the most
amazing year all around
but i felt super fortunate to be able to
have a lot of fun
talking tech online with you guys making
videos
and i just want to share a little more
of that phone with you in this so
uh in the spirit of holiday giving in
the spirit of
well starting off 2021 on the right foot
we've got a whole bunch of the most
difficult to get
hardest to find impossible to buy gaming
consoles
next-gen stuff here in front of me and
we're giving them away
as you might have been able to tell by
the title so over here we've got
a dozen ps5s and over here we've got
a dozen xbox series x and it's pretty
simple all you really got to do to get
entered
for this giveaway is just follow on
twitter follow mkbhd
and follow dbrand on twitter all the
info and links you need below
if you're already following you're
already entered to win this super simple
giveaway
uh you've probably also noticed these
look a little bit different so over here
we've got
the xbox series x with the icon skins on
them
and by the way huge shout out to
everyone who's gotten in on these this
drop was amazing and the support has
been tremendous i've seen a lot of good
installs on twitter
shout out to you guys and maybe we'll
bring it back for 2021 that would be
kind of sweet
and then over here we've got these sort
of reverse
these oreo ps5s these ice cream sandwich
ps5 so
the inside is a matte white d brand skin
you already know that plastic on the
inside scratches easily but the outside
is kind of looks like it's painted right
or maybe even a black skin
but it's just a black face plate so
dbrand's got these clipped in
black face plates that they've made
they're not actually available yet
they'll be available soon
but if you win one of these hey you'll
be early to get a face plate black and
white ps5 so
if you were to win one of these which
one would you want leave a comment down
below
uh winners will start being selected
january 1st
that's really all i got to say for this
one super simple
best of luck happy holidays and happy
new year
thanks for watching catch you guys the
next one peace
[Music]
[Music]